you or someone you care about
may have been recently diagnosed with
breast cancer
this video will help you understand some
available treatment options
breast cancer is a disease where some of
the cells in the breast begin to grow
uncontrollably treatments for breast
cancer
can include surgery radiation therapy
chemotherapy hormone therapy targeted
therapy
and immunotherapy there are several
types of surgery depending on the size
and location of the tumor
this video does not cover all available
types of breast cancer surgery
during a lumpectomy the tumor is removed
along with some of the normal tissue
around it
in a total or simple mastectomy the
entire breast is removed
during a modified radical mastectomy the
entire breast
is removed in addition some of the lymph
nodes under your arm are removed and
sometimes other tissues in your chest
your doctor may also want to give you
radiation therapy
this therapy uses radiation to kill the
cancer cells
or keep them from growing external beam
radiation uses a machine outside the
body
that aims radiation at the cancer
internal radiation therapy also known as
brachytherapy
uses a substance that gives off
radiation
through different types of delivery
devices
the substance is put inside your breast
where the cancer has been removed
chemotherapy uses certain drugs to kill
cancer
these drugs may treat cancer cells
throughout the whole body
or can be given to treat cancer cells in
one area
another treatment option is hormone
therapy
hormones are substances found naturally
in your body
estrogen is one of these hormones
your body uses estrogen mainly for the
growth and development
of your uterus breast and ovaries
however estrogen can also promote the
growth of certain hormone receptor
positive
cancer cells one type of hormone therapy
blocks estrogen from binding to breast
cancer cells
so it cannot cause cancer cells to grow
and divide
targeted therapy is a treatment option
for cancers that have a specific kind of
marker on the cancer cells
one therapy targets cells with markers
called
her2 her2
is a naturally occurring protein on your
cells
that normally promotes healthy growth in
your cells
some cancer cells have too much of this
protein
this causes the cancer cells to grow and
spread
more aggressively than normal cells
targeted therapy drugs are designed to
only attach
to the her2 proteins on cancer cells
as a result the cancer cells stop
growing
and may die
immuno-oncology also known as
immunotherapy
helps your immune system fight cancer
cancer can sometimes hide from the
immune cells that attack them
for example both cancer and immune cells
may have
proteins called checkpoint proteins
when they attach attack from other
immune cells is stopped
scientists are looking at one type of
immunotherapy
drug that blocks the checkpoint proteins
from attaching to each other
as a result the immune cell can attack
and destroy the cancer cell
your doctor may prescribe a combination
of the treatments we've discussed
or different treatment options than
those mentioned here
if you have questions about breast
cancer or any medications you have been
prescribed
talk to your doctor it is important to
take your medications as
directed and report any side effects you
have